hello so welcome to lecture three this
is going to be about classification and
regression this moves us from our first
task which we were doing last time which
was It was kind of regression how we fit
a line into a class that into a task
that will look really really similar at
first but we'll have a couple of subtle
differences and we'll go through that
which is classification remember we
talked about classification was for
discrete objects like is it what's the
animal on this photo is it a cat a pig a
horse something like that those are the
types of problems that are pretty
prevalent in machine learning and so
we'll talk through kind of those basic
issues today
what we're going to do though is we're
first going to start with this
probabilistic view of linear regression
and the reason we're going to do this is
we're going to walk through again in
that sitting where it's hopefully
relatively familiar what's going on how
we give a generative model is the the
term for it for this underlying kind of
optimization class for linear regression
so we're going to interpret it
probabilistically and that
interpretation we're going to be able to
use for classification and then again on
Wednesday for a much richer class of
models which are all these exponential
family models okay and I will assert at
a high level like to try and keep in
your head these things all look the same
we're trying to get to this an
abstraction that lets us solve them do
inference with them and kind of Reason
about them in a similar way so this is
one key building block so we'll start
with that probabilistic view of linear
regression okay
then we're going to talk about
classification and at first blush
classification is going to look just
like something we could solve with
linear regression so I just want to make
sure it's really clear in your mind when
we use classification when we use linear
regression and kind of what the little
problems are challenges are as you go
through actually doing that
then we're going to introduce the
Workhorse of machine learning logistic
regression this is something that you
know I probably use every day in some
form or another it has different names
and deep learning now and the way people
use it sometimes called like the linear
layer and soft max if you're a deep
learning Aficionado don't don't worry
about it but this is the kind of the
standard Workhorse and we can say a ton
about how linear how logistic regression
works and it was not invented by Machine
learning people this is a an old and
classical algorithm that our statistical
friends invented we use it in slightly
different ways than maybe they
originally intended and I can get into
those in a little bit now as I mentioned
there's going to be parallel structures
so we're going to talk about logistic
regression we're going to talk about for
why not linguistic regression I mean
sorry linear regression then we'll talk
about logistic regression which is
confusingly enough a classification
algorithm although it says regression in
there don't blame us blame the stats
people and then once we do that we're
going to parallel exactly as we did in
the last lecture and talk about how to
solve it okay and when we solve it
you're going to be introduced to a
method called Newton's method which
maybe you've seen if you took a kind of
a stats course at some point or a
calculus course and we'll reintroduce a
way to solve it and Newton's method when
it's applicable is really really fast
meaning it converges very quickly but
each step of that algorithm we'll see is
quite expensive and so it's not really
appropriate for a lot of the places that
machine learning people care to use it
okay so the messages from this lecture
if you get is kind of what is
classification why does it differ from
regression what is the Workhorse model
and logistic regression and then a
method to solve it and then we're going
to come back at the end and kind of
compare and contrast the different ways
that people solve these different things
right as last time there is a thread
that started online if you feel more
comfortable asking your questions
anonymously last time we had a bunch of
great questions I'd love to keep that
going super happy to to talk with you
about anything that's there but I will
keep the lecture three question thread
up on Ed if you want it
okay awesome let's get started
so we're going to start again with our
friendly squares right so just to give
you kind of the format you should think
about these tasks you're given something
and your goal is to do something with it
so we're given some x i and y i
right for I equals 1 to n
and recall this is the training set and
right and in this case
x i oops
x i
lives in some r d or Rd plus 1 as our
convention is D plus one recall because
we had that convention that there was a
bias term where every every single entry
had a one appended to it if you remember
that from last time if not don't worry
just remember like why is there D plus
one there it's by convention
and we had a Target variable Y and this
target variable which I'll I'll
highlight in purple
this target variable was a real valued
number right so this is picture picture
align for the moment okay
and our goal was that we wanted to find
some Theta
element of also r d plus one
such that
Theta was the argument or very very
close to it because remember ARG man we
can't really solve these exactly even
though we like it over Theta of
sum I equals 1 to n
y i minus h of theta X of I
squared where
h of theta X of I
equals Theta dot X actually I'm just
going to remove the x i because I don't
care
true for any example
okay I'll put transpose here just to
make sure it's clear we I have a DOT
there but
awesome okay now I'm using this slightly
more General notation this h of theta
and that looks like a little bit of
overkill for a DOT product but we're
going to use that in several ways
through the next couple of lectures so
apologies for that if you remember here
we had this the way we Define this Theta
is we said oh it minimizes the losses or
the residuals squared we didn't give any
justification for this and what we want
to do is go in this next part go kind of
one level deeper and ask this kind of
why question why did we pick to minimize
the sum of squares now this will
introduce us to one of our favorite
friends in this course which is the
gaussian distribution and we'll talk
about why that's a plausible thing to do
right you could ask why the gaussian
distribution and I can wax with you
philosophical I'll give you a sense of
it but we'll come back to that in one
second so our goal is okay we have this
equation but kind of where did it come
from and by thinking about where does it
come from that's going to tell us how to
generalize it right that's the that's
the plan for what we're up to
all right so
this is our first model in the class
really like generative model we're going
to assume
that y i
looks as follows it's going to equal
Theta t x i
I'm going to unpack this in one second
plus some Epsilon I and this character
here this is an error or a noise term
okay
all right so let's unpack this because
the first time we're seeing one of these
things okay so this thing here maybe
this makes sense to you you're like oh
there exists some true Theta that's out
there that's what this is saying this
model is saying there's some Theta maybe
I'll call it Theta star just to make
sure it's clear
there's some Theta star that's out there
some you know one that's hidden from us
but all of my data was generated by the
taking that parameter with the features
and generating the Y okay this would be
a situation where all of your data laid
perfectly on a line right because it's
just saying that like you know given the
features I know exactly what y's value
is now what we're saying is something
that's not quite that strong that's that
would be a noiseless situation we're
adding in a little bit of noise and when
machine Learners or statisticians say
noise what they mean is like stuff we
can't really explain that's the kind of
thing to think about it we're modeling
it up to this okay and maybe we know a
little bit about the noise and we'll
talk about what we might expect from
noise in a second but like we expect
that there's some kind of random
gyration maybe this accounts for in kind
of physical settings some measurement
error right some classical Jitter that's
underneath the covers maybe there's
something where you know if you're more
kind of sophisticated Bayesian you think
it's you know subject to your
information I only know the features X
and there's some unmodeled piece that's
in the noise and I'm willing to kind of
minimize that okay
so what are the properties you would
want of this error okay
so this is a forward model by the way it
tells me I don't know Theta but I know
how my data is generated right that's
what I mean when I say generative models
like I know if you give me an x i and
presumably knew how to construct Epsilon
you could get a y i value okay now we
don't get to see Epsilon I by the way it
doesn't appear in the training set it's
just a mental model for how the data are
actually linked together okay and that's
going to be fairly important when we
start to generalize these models right
they have certain kinds of Errors we can
characterize Okay so
what are the properties that we would
expect
of Epsilon I
okay so first notice that it's Epsilon
super I that is that noise is different
per Tuple it's not like there's some
noise offset that was just added to all
our data and shifted every single point
if you like we're going to have a random
model you get a random sample from that
noise okay and that's what determines
what the y i is okay right so what would
you expect from that well it's random
we probably want something
where the expected value over all the
Epsilon I's over over that random
process is zero this is sometimes mean
it's unbiased
okay
now this is on one hand like a deep
philosophical statement and other hand
kind of a trivial statement the Deep
philosophical statement is we're kind of
saying that these errors if you think
about it's kind of unreasonable like if
I average over infinitely many of them
they're not going to appreciably change
what the true y value is right they
don't have any information that's inside
the model that's really what it's saying
I may still get a sample where Epsilon I
is 0.1 or 0.2 or negative point one
whatever their value is but on average
I'm just making a statement of the
population like I don't care about this
value it's going to be averaged away to
zero in a precise sense okay now on the
other hand if it were not a zero value
that would be kind of a strange thing
because we have a bias term suggests
that you could actually just kind of
incorporate that standing bias in the
Theta star okay so I don't want to go
too far down that path but like
operationally this is not an
unreasonable thing to say and I want you
to think about it as kind of a statement
of information like I modeled all the
features in the X's right those are all
my my features the house price remember
the the lot size all that stuff and
there's some thing I haven't modeled
maybe the house looks a little bit nicer
maybe it reminds people of where they
grew grew up as children maybe it was
you know that there's like a famous
house or something that probably doesn't
count for noise but there's something
about it that's unmodeled as a statement
of information okay
the second thing is a little bit more
subtle
the second thing is that the errors are
independent
okay now we don't always make this
but this is going to allow us to do some
pretty healthy mathematics and let's
talk about why what would happen if it
failed and what this means formally is
I'm going to write down a strong form
it says that these two things equal the
expected value of Epsilon I and I mean
it in a very strong sense if you know
about various different Notions of
Independence and uncorrelation
don't worry
okay all right this is for I not equal
to J that's what that little little
piece is here let me write it bigger so
you see it 4i not equal to J
okay what does this mean okay so if you
remember your notion of Independence
what we're saying here is that they're
statistically independent and I mean in
a really strong sense like knowing the
error for one Tuple doesn't tell me
anything about the error for another
Tuple this is consistent with my earlier
kind of interpretation of Errors like
how much information I know about it if
I did know something about that error
and I could model it then I'd have to
have a kind of a more complicated model
here okay
all right any questions about this so
far
all right awesome
okay now with this setup
there's one other thing so so far I made
two assumptions at this stage I hope you
think they're like plausible to make
progress and that's one of the things by
the way about machine learning that I
think people kind of get uncomfortable
about I certainly was when I first
started in kind of statistical modeling
that like you're like well is that
really true ah kind of not the right
question to ask it's like is it a useful
assumption to make to make progress like
what am I giving up by making it which
is a much harder thing to assess it's
not ever true like if you look at real
errors they're very infrequently
gaussian distributed right that's kind
of terrifying why do we use it
everywhere well it still works pretty
well because we're not assuming too much
about the underlying data now if you
know something about that data we'll
come back in the next lecture and tell
you how to put more information about
the error but I just want you to get a
sense like okay these are kind of
strange modeling constructs
now one thing that we'll care about
which is a function of this is how noisy
is it
we need a measure of noise and so a
natural thing to assume
is that and we we can relax this
assumption let's imagine that they're
all kind of a uniform background of
Noise Okay so everyone has the same
variance this is a standard variance
assumption okay the sigma squared so
there's noise we don't know anything
about it we know it's unbiased and we
know that it has about the same
magnitude it's not wildly different on
some piece of our data versus others and
again it's kind of like a statement of
you know if you want to be really
philosophical like an ignorance prior
like we don't know anything so how would
we know that this part of our data has
more noise than the other okay it's just
an assumption to make progress
please
[Music]
until like the expected value of that
square oh because it's oh yeah so this
the variance here the variance formally
is Epsilon squared minus the MU so
normally we have a variance but I've
alighted that because the the uh this
first term is zero so it is actually the
variance I just wrote it as the square
there so it is Epsilon minus the MU the
MU is just zero wonderful question thank
you so much for that please
so the error here is a sample from a
value so it's actually a discrete value
that's underneath the covers so it's
like the way to picture it is like
imagine I don't know I hate invoking
deities but like imagine there's God and
she's got her table right and then you
got the value of all the x's and she has
her Theta zero and she produces a y then
for whatever reason she adds a little
error to it that error is a specific
specific scalar that changed y from 0.2
to 0.4 and I'm just saying that's the
piece that we want to model and the
reason we want to model that is because
what we're coming to
so does that make sense the types check
it's a it's a scale or not not a
function there
the the reason we want to get to that is
we're going to solve this problem kind
of up to noise and we're going to worry
a lot in the theory we won't do it too
much in this lecture but we worry a lot
in the theory of like could we solve it
up to the noise floor like if you're
making decisions that depend on how like
noisy it is and your data is you know
has a sigma squared of one and you're
trying to make decisions where your
values are like 0.1 apart intuitively
something should be wrong there you're
kind of reading into the noise so we'll
worry a lot about how our procedure
scale with the noise so you can kind of
think about this as saying like there's
some average noise and you know it's
noisier or not if it were zero then our
data is perfectly clean
okay that's the way to think about it
for now and if my explanations about
like scaling and other stuff seem like
obtuse and weird please don't worry
about it we'll come back to a picture of
the gaussian and it'll be hopefully a
little bit clearer in a second
okay other questions
all right now here's the remarkable
thing here's how the gaussian comes up
it comes up for a really interesting
reason which is if I tell you that I
want a distribution such that uh it's
unbiased
and it has this Sigma squared I know
it's variance and I assume nothing else
about it right the bayesians used to
make a lot of a lot of noise about this
then that distribution is uniquely the
gaussian okay so you don't have to know
that in some fundamental sense but it
leads you to this conclusion that is a
distribution that has these two
properties and you're not assuming
things about how it's like third and
fourth moments like if you wrote a three
or a four there I don't have to assume
what they are right they're they're just
given okay
okay so let's see
um
if I can skip to it okay
so it turns out this is the unique
distribution this is unique in some
sense that doesn't really matter too
much that's more like philosophical of
the above
and I've been a little bit too imprecise
to really appreciate that but that you
should kind of take away okay so this is
our our friend the gaussian let's go
through the notation first of what we
mean so this Epsilon I here getting to
the great question earlier is what it
what it says is Epsilon I is drawn this
is what the twiddle means drawn
distributed to n of mu Sigma squared and
I'm going to draw that in a second this
is a normal distribution means this is
the mean
this is the mean of that normal
distribution
and this is the variance
okay and here's a picture of it we'll
get to it in one second okay right this
is the mean right here
and this is kind of how the distribution
looks and so Epsilon the way it's picked
is I will sample with probability
proportional to the height of this curve
right here maybe I pick a value here and
that's how I get the Epsilon I and I'm
repeatedly drawing from this underlying
distribution okay that's what that's the
mental model I have of Epsilon now is
that actually what's going on I don't
know don't know God don't know how that
works but it's our model of how the
world is going okay
sound good
all right
now as we go through this a couple
things this distribution is actually
fairly peaked
um so maybe you've seen this like a
central limit theorem or something
before in earlier classes at some point
you've seen this idea that if I take a
bunch of things and add them together
they kind of converge to this
distribution I won't make that statement
precise but there's a reason this thing
kind of comes up if you have a bunch of
additive errors they end up looking when
you average over all of them they end up
looking gaussian okay so if you have a
lot of little tiny additive errors they
end up looking gaussian there's too much
Philosophy for why this thing shows up
if none of that matters to you don't
worry it shows up and we're going to use
it okay all right
so just to make sure you understand this
function and what it looks like here's
the mean value of it if you see the
sigma version so this is the square root
of that Sigma squared you see that
within one Sigma you have
um here 63 percent of the or 69 percent
of the mass these are by the way these
notes you can go download the templates
and they will have those things and this
picture is from Wikipedia so you can
also just look there please
uh we will do a lot with population
statistics we will not do things with
sampling until a couple of key points
and the difference between those two
will be kind of immaterial when we do
the actual salts but it's a great
question yeah
and if that doesn't make sense to you
don't worry
yeah so in our setting before when we
had Epsilon I that's exactly right I
should have written this for us great
call this should be zero for our Epsilon
I in general this is the notation so mu
is equal to zero
mu equals zero great point
okay
awesome all right another thing is this
is the function right here that we're
looking at now when you look at this you
start to see why least squares may come
up there's this quadratic looking thing
in here okay there's a one-half and
there's a sigma squared and whatever
this is the normalizing constant that's
just if I integrate the entire area
under this curve this function that just
makes sure that it's one that's a PDF
okay that's all that thing is you'll see
it a bunch of times in various different
guises here okay but this is the
function okay now let me unpack this
notation for you you may not have seen
this before
this is not conditional we'll come back
to this I'll hammer on this a couple of
times this says the probability
distribution density of Z and then this
semicolon is not conditional formally it
means these are the parameters of the
distribution you don't condition on the
parameters this may be a little bit
pedantic but we will stick to this in
the class you have mu and sigma Square
those are like things you plug in right
so why does this matter
when we reason about the the normal
distribution we're going to have these
parameters the mean and the sigma
squared we just plug them in and then it
gives us a distribution okay and that's
going to come back in one second when we
get to what's called a likelihood
function okay these are our parameters
let me write that on here
these are our parameters
okay is the notation clear
if you're familiar with conditioning
this is not conditioning you can still
condition you can write it in a bar and
we'll do that in one or two steps you
should be familiar with conditional
probability for this class not the most
advanced versions of it but you know
basically what it does
okay awesome all right so now let's
write something that's conditional
so what is the probability of y i
given x i
and as we said
I'll write here Theta who or right here
Theta which is our underlying parameter
well it's going to equal
what
1 over square root 2 pi that's the
normalizing bit I'm going to move this
down
sorry
X of and then here it's y i
minus Theta x i
squared over 2 Sigma Square
okay so far so good
okay so this is the probability
distribution what does this it says
given that I saw x i I saw the feature
what is the probability distribution
over the y i what value should I expect
okay to come out of this right
and that I have this Theta model which
is our parameter here okay so our
parameter
okay
we could put Sigma squared in there too
okay now we'll write this in a more
compact form
x i
okay this is the bar okay so this is now
the conditional probability okay it says
given that I saw x i condition on all
the probability distributions under
Theta this is the probability
distribution over y i and I'll often
write that this is this conditional
distribution is n of theta t x
I Sigma squared so this mouthful is the
same as this mouthful does that make
sense this is just notation at this
point and hopefully the fact that it's a
generative model kind of adds up go
ahead foreign
yeah so great question so here what I'm
saying is I'm basically asserting by
Fiat that because the only random
variable is Epsilon I that x i here like
so this really is there's a the
difference between these characters
right here is Epsilon I right that was
by Fiat in the model when I did it
earlier right I said oops sorry to
scroll I I really wish it didn't look so
nauseating but it does so because of
this model I could substitute in here so
this value here is nothing more than
Epsilon super I and just a different
guys which tells me all these pieces but
it has to be conditioned on x i because
I saw that like I saw that variable when
I had to add it in right so that's how I
get a distribution over y i
wonderful questions are there more yeah
yeah oh yeah so someone asked on the
thing is e-i-e-i the the product of the
two and the answer is yes
thanks for the question
someone's asking if this is the product
up here
and yes this is the product these are
just multiplied by one another there's
no hidden operation there
yeah sorry the graph paper makes sure
that I write in a line otherwise like
I'll end up writing all crazy but I can
understand it's not awesome for
rendering other questions
foreign
okay so why did we do all this maybe I
just like torturing you with notation
the truth is I really don't like
notation but we're going to use this in
several different ways and so hopefully
right now you can kind of piece it
together and say like okay I kind of
could see a model underneath here and
what we're going to do is we're going to
try and justify the optimization that we
did for least squares by picking the
most likely parameter so let me explain
what we mean okay so before I do that
notice here one fact that I've kind of
hidden from you a little bit picking
Theta
picks a distribution let me make sure
that claim is clear before I move on
okay what do I mean once you tell me
Theta and I have the data fixed then all
the distribution over the Y Eyes Are
Fixed
does that make sense so in some sense by
picking a Theta right once I have the
sigma squared fixed I'm picking a
distribution now over all what the Y I
should be
and that's going to be interesting
because what it means is as you pick a
different Theta I can compare how well
does it line up with my data so
intuitively right if I pick a Theta all
my data lies on a line and I pick the
Theta that exactly fits the line that
should be much more likely than if I
pick a different Theta where it's
scattered my predictions are scattered
all over the place
and they're really far away so that the
thin parts of this
so let's come down and write that a
little bit more precisely but that's the
intuition of what's going on here okay
so ask me ask me a question about that
okay so for this we need a notion which
will be very much used in this class
which is the notion of likelihoods
and this allows us to pick among many
distributions
okay so at first that sounds pretty
fancy like how are we going to pick
among these distributions right it's a
huge unmeasurable class if you know what
that is all this nasty stuff but we just
have to pick in our situation among the
different thetas that could fit our data
okay and we're going to pick the one
that is most likely
so let's write that down right now
so what is the likelihood of theta okay
it's going to be
the probability of all the Y's given all
the X's
given Theta right or can or with input
Theta
okay
this just says How likely the date is
and clearly as I vary Theta I'm going to
get different scores here for How
probabilistically likely all the Y's are
let's break it apart if it doesn't make
perfect sense what that statement means
when I start to write it out
mechanically hopefully you'll see how it
decomposes and then please ask me a
question
I'm going to write something which at
first may look actually I'm going to
write here
a bit unmotivated
I can break this down into many smaller
assumptions
or many smaller pieces
okay why is this the case
why can I take the big thing and turn it
into a product of the Small Things what
am I using
exactly I'm using Independence and the
strong form of Independence which I
which I kept bringing up that told me
that I could write this big product over
all the vectors
as this as this product among all of
them okay and sometimes you'll hear this
referred to as the IID assumption
independent and identically distributed
okay
all right
cool please
yeah so Theta there should be a zero and
a sigma squared I'm being a little bit
glib about what happens with the I could
imagine a model this is a wonderful
question thank you for letting me say
this I could imagine a model where
because the way I've specified the model
it's implicit that mu is always zero but
I haven't told you what Sigma squared is
for right now imagine that Sigma squared
is fixed I told it to you ahead of time
so I don't have to plug it in here I
could also fit it right I could look at
my data and see among all the thetas
that are there and all the noise levels
what's the most likely one and that's
actually a slightly different model but
here I'm imagining that Sigma squared is
fixed but it should kind of go under
this rubric and you're like why are you
being so sloppy about that and the
reason is because later we're going to
be much sloppier about it because we're
going to introduce notation that says
it's all the parameters in the problem
okay but wonderful question you're
exactly on on target for this look
please
foreign
no no so here we have this probability
because it's conditioned on X we've
removed all the dependence on the data
so like everyone gets to see all the
data and now all that's left that's
unspecified in the model is the
epsilonize if they were all zeros you'd
be able to get the Y eyes exactly but
the only Randomness that's left is that
Epsilon I that's what we're doing and
that's kind of what we cheated on here
when we we said this guy is really
Epsilon I as well wonderful questions
you folks are really on top of this the
other questions
please
[Music]
no no so there's there's really not
there's really not much to to say here
all that there is is we went through
this model where we said why eyes are of
this form now that we've conditioned on
x i we know this and we're plugging in
Theta so you're giving me a particular
Theta to evaluate and now Epsilon I is a
randomly is a random variable it has yet
to be determined so there's a
distribution over that the distribution
of Epsilon I is given by this equation
because this is exactly equal to Epsilon
I and so this now gives me a say I don't
know what Epsilon is but it has a
distribution that looks like this so if
I sampled it that's a weird statement I
want to be clear that's a really weird
statement it means that if I picked
enough Epsilon I's I'd expect it's mean
to be here whatever mu was in this case
zero and I'd expect kind of the scatter
plot to look like it was inside here or
like actually the histogram to look kind
of like this like if I bend how many
were in each thing and eventually
converging to this distribution that's
exactly what I mean
awesome questions these are great
okay
oops all right
oh man I even had it down here all
written nicely sorry
um we'll go back to my messy version
okay so here we've gone from from this
piece to this piece and then here all
I'm doing is because these are the
Epsilon I's which I've we've assumed
Independence in the strongest way I can
move to a product okay we will do this
throughout the course a lot of machine
learning is based on IID because it's an
okay assumption does that mean the
errors are not correlated no no of
course they're correlated but we're not
modeling it that's all it means it's not
true it's just a good model
okay great now I substitute in one more
thing
equals
product i1 to n and then I'm just going
to write out the distribution
Sigma 2 pi
times
X
of
so y oh sorry
what did I maybe forget a minus sign why
I
minus Theta x i
Square over two
Sigma Square okay why did I do this all
right so I just wrote this whole thing
out oops I just wrote this whole thing
out
right
now the reason is we don't use this so
minimizing this seems like a nightmare
and so what we do instead is we use a
simple transformation of this
which will make it nice and additive
which is called the log likelihood
okay all right now I want to make sure
of one thing let me go back there should
be a minus here I messed that up this
has to be the it has to be a positive
square otherwise it will spiral off to
Infinity I'm sorry this isn't my lizard
brain I messed that up okay clear enough
they're Epsilon here right otherwise
it's the wrong shape yeah please
oh two questions one is there a negative
in the original formula also yes
period
yeah
I made a mistake
one two three yes
oh exponential function so it just means
this this character here
sorry about this x of X it may be more
familiar to you as e to the x
there's no e to the power x and x is
everything in the bracket everything in
the bracket
wait I thought the original function was
appropriate because effectively we're
competing a negative
scene by doing the real minus the
predicted rather no it's squared right
so this character's School great point
it's my mistake
awesome
okay is that clear I don't want to make
sure that's clear it's a small detail
and it is in the notes maybe I don't
know
all right okay so far so good
all right
wonderful okay so we have this function
with all of our with all of my bugs that
I've introduced that we're catching on
the Fly which is awesome we're going to
introduce a new function
it's going to be the log of our old
function say why are you doing that and
the reason is what is law what does log
do for X functions well it brings the
contents down right which is nice and it
also uh separates out things that are
products so we have a big product we
take a log we turn into a big sum that
sum looks a little bit more like what we
were expecting intuitively
from our
from our least squares let me write it
here so it's sum
I equals 1 to n right because we turn
this product into a sum
1 over Sigma 2 pi
minus
y i minus Theta x i
Square over 2 Sigma okay
I just took the log of the exponential
please
[Music]
oh log Sigma excellent point
let me move this
oops yeah it should be log Sigma
you can see where their typos and things
I don't care about that term is going to
disappear in a second but awesome
awesome find yeah
Okay cool so what do I care about here
the thing I was just about to say is
this term doesn't depend in any way on
Theta
right
and so remember when we talked about
minimizing the the loss function we're
like oh if I added a constant it didn't
matter and this is a constant the sigma
squared that doesn't depend on my data
anyway so I can just kind of toss it
away in contrast
this thing very much does depend on my
data and Theta right
comes on data
and Theta
is that clear
yeah please
submission side is sort of a blue trip
so think about it like this
yeah sorry
awesome questions
yeah wonderful
okay so now
what does that mean
if I want to find the most likely
function that corresponds to doing what
I claim it corresponds to Max over Theta
L of theta
why is that the case Well Log is a
monotone transformation right so this
original thing I wanted to maximize the
probability log is monotone right looks
like this and all the rest and so log of
theta is the same as as maximizing that
then this term is just a constant we
talked about how that doesn't really
matter too much so I can drop that term
and then I have a minus here so it's the
same as
minimizing over Theta
1 over 2 sum i1 to n
y i minus Theta x i
Square
and then you say well what about that
Sigma squared what happened to it
well as we talked about last time it
doesn't matter if you scale the loss by
a constant it's still the same minimizer
we don't care about the value and what
is this character that's least squares
okay and we call this thing j Theta
right this was J Theta in the last
lecture
okay so what was important here I walked
through this fairly slowly
um and what I the reason I wanted to
walk through it like this and you should
run through this is because we're going
to run this same Playbook again and
again we're going to talk about what the
error is for these these kind of linear
models then we're going to try and
reduce them to this likelihood
computation oops
this likelihood computation will almost
always use the log because it turns it
into an additive problem and remember
stochastic gradient descent likes to
work on additive problems
this is of a nice form that we like to
deal with and then we solve the
underlying equation and so there'll be
kind of this mapping that I give you a
distribution and then out comes a loss
function and that's going to be nearly
automatic after this lecture in the next
lecture to be able to do that for a
pretty wide class of models then how do
we solve them it turns out we're going
to solve them all the same way
awesome
okay so is that clear is the
probabilistic interpretation of least
squares or fitting a line clear please
please go ahead
foreign
[Music]
so if you had Sigma Square here I'm not
going to show you how to fit this right
now but there's another model where you
have it this is called with known
variance this is what I call fixed
design with known variance uh linear
regression if you also don't know the
sigma squared you have to learn that too
and there's a parameter right Sigma
comes out it doesn't come out quite
nicely to the least squares formulation
you have to do a little bit of extra
work to estimate Sigma but you can do it
and I think it may be a homework problem
so I'm not going to tell you too much
more about it but it's not it's not
complicated yeah
it shouldn't be complicated but great
question for now we're assuming Sigma
squared is given you do not need to make
that assumption please
no either way all right all good all
right so
um at this point we've gone through that
that interpretation let me make sure if
there's anything else
fantastic all right
let's talk about classification
little primer on classification this is
where we are we're going to talk about
how classification works why regression
isn't the thing that we would
necessarily want to do in this scenario
and then we're going to run the same
Playbook I assert to be able to solve
the model okay
uh that is estimate the Theta underneath
the covers all right so here what is
classification what are we given
we're given not surprisingly X I's and Y
is no change so far
4 I equal one
to n
okay but y i we're going to work on
binary classification in zero one okay
and the values of zero and one aren't
super critical you could have minus one
and one I actually prefer that because
it makes some of the math a little bit
nicer that's not what we're doing in the
course you could have just categorical
values there are discrete encodings of
the variables okay now
we often think in terminology why I also
like the minus one we call this often
the negative class
this is just convention right there's no
intrinsic meaning to these things this
is our model and this the positive class
okay
so like a negative Class A positive
class could be we found the tumor right
there is a tumor in this image versus
the negative classes there's no tumor or
this is a cat this is not a cat right
we're doing binary right now you can do
multi-class which we'll come to later
which is you know there's a cat a dog a
pig a horse right now we're just doing
two okay
okay great so you look at this data and
you're like oh okay I plotted it you've
told me there's zero one encoded so you
could use basically so we can use linear
algebra and Vector techniques and all
the rest so zero one here's some data
right and you're like oh why don't you
just fit a line right like I should just
like you know kind of fit a line maybe
the line kind of like I don't know goes
through here or something like this and
it's fine right
and indeed for a lot of problems if you
run linear regression and just kind of
say like is it closer to Cloud to one
than zero and round at the end like you
can get out a classifier
but it kind of feels a little bit weird
especially because your data there's no
reason it should be nicely clustered
what if like there were a blue point all
the way over here or over here or way
over here what's going to happen to your
line well it's going to start because
it's fitting those residuals to go
crazier and crazier if you like in this
direction right naturally it's going to
skew more and more towards more of the
data and so whatever decision boundary
you kind of put there you're going to
get into kind of stranger and stranger
situations okay now that's just a
motivation for why you want to treat
something that's natively categorical
so let's
let's go through the function here maybe
you've seen this in a stats course
already
this is logistics or logistic regression
so we're going to do one trick here over
linear regression our hypothesis is
going to generate something of X is
going to live in 0 1.
okay so this is a graph here of zero one
uh that we're going to get to in one
second
and H of theta of x
is going to be written as
G of theta t x
where which will equal
uh 1 plus e to the minus Theta TX
over 1. okay now this function here G of
Z
equals 1 over 1 plus e of Z
this is called a link function
okay the terminology sometimes also
called an inverse link function the
literature goes back and forth doesn't
really matter so you say why did you do
this well our model is still going to be
linear in our features but we're going
to feed it through this non-linearity
and that non-linearity is all of a
sudden going to make sure that it kind
of saturates when it gets too big and
saturates when it gets too small so it's
not going to have the behavior if we
looked at our old data right let's go
back up to our old data it's going to
kind of have a function that looks more
like this
does that make sense but at least at a
high level
okay
so that's the intuition okay and this
function here has a special name it's
the sigmoid so you may see that if you
use you know modern deep learning
packages you'll see sigmoids or things
floating around that's what they are
they're just this function that kind of
Smooths it over now you may ask like why
don't I use a different link function
you could there are lots of different
link functions to use
this is by far the most popular for a
variety of reasons one is that you can
turn it into kind of what they call
probabilistic estimates which we'll get
to a little bit later
please
[Music]
yeah let's get through great question
how do we how do you do multi-class
let's first get through how we actually
do the binary class that's a great
question you can think about a standard
way to do multi-class is to do what's
called One versus all if it bothers you
where you say am I in class one or any
other class class two or any other class
and you can kind of you can put them
that way there are more sophisticated
schemes there's a wonderful paper from
20 2004 that talks about how those more
sophisticated schemes don't always pan
out and it's written in a very
aggressive style which I find
interesting and entertaining Anyway by a
guy from the media lab
Okay cool so
at first this looks kind of weirdly
motivated but there's there's some
motivation for it which is just that it
has this nice property and it's smooth
and it kind of looks close to like a
threshold function now the other thing
when I say it's smooth is we could also
Imagine the function that was like a
step function that you could use that
right that seems like a natural thing
when you're below zero then you know
return when you're when you're negative
return uh you know zero when you're a
positive return one right that would be
a thing you could do in deep learning
these are sometimes called you know
there's there's you know it's a sine
function the problem is the derivatives
would give you no information here right
if they were flat so this is smooth so
like it tells you like a kind of a nice
smooth transition and that will work
better with modern optimization that's
one thing we want out of it please
let's explain
what h of X and G of Z are with this
functions name uh remember recall this
is the same notation we had earlier this
is the hypothesis sub Theta this says
how do we do prediction so the way I do
prediction in this model
um in the logistic regression model is
you've given me Theta which is some
parameters that you have that chooses
your model then you give me some X which
recall is like your data point and then
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
produce a number between 0 and 1. and
the way I'm going to produce it is I'm
going to run I'm going to take their dot
product as I was doing before and then
I'm going to run it through this
function and I'll come to in one second
how we interpret those scores but you
can think about those scores as being
closer to one means I'm confident it's
in the class and closer to zero means
I'm not confident in the class and what
I was saying is this function looks like
it was picked out of a hat and it really
wasn't the reason it wasn't is it has a
couple of properties it's smooth and it
transitions nicely between zero and one
and I was trying to explain why those
properties were important and so that's
where H data links to this image does
that make sense
the key of beta transfers
isn't actually equal to the thing to the
right of it in the parentheses it is so
so if you look G is this function here
but Z is a scalar right and so it's just
substituting in Theta TX for Z
yeah I just wrote it this way so I'd
have more room to write the numerator
and then here I wrote it one over
because that's the more standard way to
write they're equivalent great questions
please
oh yeah a link function is a general
class of G that you could apply that's
some kind of non-linearity one that you
may have seen if you ever played with a
deep learning package of something
called relu or rectified linear it looks
like this
right so there are other link functions
that are out there there's probits and
logits and all kinds of things we're
going to use this one but I want you to
be aware of it because I think you have
to to try one other link function on a
homework and the phrase is used in the
literature and it's very mysterious if
you don't hear it first
very good questions
sometimes it's also called an inverse
link function that's a separate issue
cool
awesome all right so how do we interpret
those scores
now this is the twist that gets us into
probabilistic modeling
which we're going to generalize so we
say the probability that y equals one
according to the model
is equal to H Theta of x
now
this is a testable statement okay now
just to complete it also what's the
probability y equals zero this is going
to be proportional to X Theta of one
minus H Theta of X Y because probability
is sum to one okay we only have two
classes
now this is actually testable if you
took a bunch of data and put it through
and looked at the probabilities and bend
them
right so you took all the predictions
that were between 0.5 and 0.6 and 0.6
and 0.7 and you counted them up in every
bucket how many were accurate
this is testable you can see if the
model is what's called calibrated okay
and that's very useful that like the
errors are meaningful and so you can
check that it's a it's more of a
condition than they're right or wrong
now in modern machine learning that's
less important but you will hear people
talk about like the probabilities or the
scores that come out of these models and
using those scores for something and
this is what they mean
they'll sometimes use the log of this
which is called the logit
okay but that's how we interpret what
the model tells us that's why this link
function is important that it's between
0 and 1.
cool
it doesn't damage optimization it's not
obvious but it doesn't damage
optimization is the other major thing
okay so let's use that information to
write our likelihood function
the probability of Y I'll emphasize that
it's a vector this time x I don't really
like that notation but it's okay
is well why did we get here
oops
well this is again the independence
assumption kind of rearing it's you know
ugly or not head right we're able to go
from the entire data set to a product
over all the terms
nothing surprising there and then we'll
write this in one form which hopefully
makes a little bit of sense
x i
this seems like a cheat but it's
actually okay
1 minus H Theta
okay so why does this seem like a cheat
it's a weird way to do it okay but it'll
come become nice in a second so what I'm
writing here is I'm saying the
probability is the probability I said
that it was true now what is y i when y
i is 1 I select this term
because this term is zero right so think
about when Y is one this character is
one this character is zero so this goes
to one and this is the only term that
matters when the true label is is one
it's exactly reversed okay when it's
zero I should say when it's zero this
term is one and then this term goes away
does that make sense just think through
like the cases y i zero or y i is one
so far so good so it's kind of like
encoding both simultaneously I get to
see why I so really only one is present
but it just makes my arithmetic a little
bit cleaner below does that encoding
make sense
cool right
all right so let's take the log of L
Theta
we're doing exactly the same thing that
we did before
one to n
now I'm going to write it write this out
it's one i y I log
H Theta x i
plus 1 minus y i
log
and oops
one minus H Theta x i
okay so so far so good
but now notice
this is in exactly the form that I need
for SGD to run
that's pretty wild
okay this is just a sum over everything
I can just write gradient descent or
anything else I wanted in terms of the
thetas and I'm all good these are these
are functioned underneath the covers now
one other thing which I won't arrive but
you can see very easily from this
okay so just just to be clear same
recipe I want to write down what I mean
by same recipe
we have Theta t plus one equals Theta t
minus Alpha
Theta I
J Theta
now when we do this something oh so
right now actually we're sorry we're
gonna do gradient Ascent because where
this is still maximizing probability we
haven't pulled out a negative term sorry
about that
but one interesting thing pops out
so you should verify this we'll see if
we can do it we won't do it in class but
you should see if you can you can do
this
Theta J
of come on
of L Theta
equals the sum I goes from 1 to n
of
y i minus H Theta x i
times x i j
okay so this is pretty miraculous if you
look at this what it says is if I look
actually at this underlying function and
I take the derivative it comes out in
exactly the same form that we had when
we were doing linear regression it's
your prediction error
times the X I now the prediction itself
is different right before the prediction
was just Theta dot x i now it's this
this H function but this gives me
something I'm like these models are very
very similar right they're like how much
error do I make then take a gradient
step with respect to the data that that
tries to minimize that error and so this
is the sense in which I mean like these
models really all are kind of like all
the same we're twisting these pieces at
the edge for how we model things
okay and so that means actually after
you you pop all this stuff out you can
use exactly the same Rule and this rule
is extremely General
okay and that's surprising like this
rule of like I just take my predictor
and then I do and I do the derivative
like that's kind of shocking that like a
large class of models and in fact that's
what we're going to generalize in the
next lecture to make sure that we
understand exactly the breadth of that
any questions to this part of what we're
talking about please
oh right great question so remember the
reason that we got this minus sign here
sorry to go back oh
the minus sign was our was our Nemesis
the last time that popped out and so
this turned our Max
into a min
right we didn't have a minus sign here
and we were maximizing the the loss that
we put in and I didn't I didn't oops
I didn't change anything so when we were
we never had a minus sign pop out of
here but when you actually go through
and see it a minus sign does pop out you
have to take my word for it or you just
do the calculation see
okay but here that's why we have
gradient descent because we're
maximizing the loss not minimizing the
underlying function
please
oh this is XJ is the jth component so
here I did this J's are the same so I
was taking the derivative with respect
to the jth component of theta and so
that's the underlying derivative same
way if you remember in the linear
regression we calculated the the
derivative with respect to each
component independently
exactly right well if this is yeah this
is the exactly right yeah I don't have
anything to add now
um
yeah
oh great great question why I is the
label so and here that's what I was
saying I said in an extremely confusing
way for some reason so why I is fixed I
know why I get to see why I it's a label
so when I have y i is equal to zero then
this term is zero so this thing is just
one and this is the term that's inside
it's like a switch statement when y i is
1 which I get to see right for the
values that it's one then only then this
statement goes away and I and I have
only this character if I could draw
faster with colors that's a terrible
color here we go
does that make sense so it switches
between both based on what Y is it's
just a compact encoding of both cases
that's why it's a little bit awkward
yeah great question please
so we compute it so the the thing here
is this derivative here this this log
and I'll make sure this is clear we
wanna like this I'm asserting I haven't
shown you this but the way you compute
it is you take the derivative you put it
inside you say Okay y i doesn't depend
on Theta this term does you compute the
derivative of this character internally
and then that is what I'm saying you can
simplify it to down here but you you
compute it like that's up to you to do
once the model is in this form you just
use the rules of calculus to compute it
yeah exactly this follows this notation
I will use reflexively without thinking
this is the log likelihood
I mean change colors
Yep this is the log likelihood
and this is the likelihood
likelihood
okay this is on the probabilities this
is on the logs of them great questions
cool please
so we'll almost always do gradient
descent so one rule of the course or not
rule but one thing is you typically use
the log likelihoods for a variety of
reasons but one is that they're nice for
optimization and so that's what this
link is meant to show you
very cool
awesome
all right I will pause a second
all right so at this phase right now
we've seen another model what we're
going to see next lecture is we're going
to generalize this with a little bit
more math and so the thing is it's like
you know maybe it's a terrible terrible
metaphor but like you know a frog with
boiling water or whatever but like
you're you're getting more complexity
and you're not noticing it right we
started at lines like I know how to fit
a line then we had some probability
distributions okay they came in and then
we started these predictors that were
actually instead of just giving you a
value of regression they were actually
giving you a probability we interpreted
those as log likelihoods now we're going
to make next lecture we're going to make
the probabilities more complex and
that's going to allow us to to
generalize
before we do that I want to show you one
other thing which is the which is the
Newton's method which is another
solution method so that we can compare
and contrast with stochastic gradient
descent and give you a chance to ask
questions since we were a little rushed
at the end of last lecture because I
screwed up okay sound good all right
okay so let's talk about Newton's method
we're now talking about forget about
your modeling side now we're talking
about optimization right so
Newton's method is the following we're
going to be given
some f from RD to D it's got to be a
scalar out
okay at this point actually doesn't but
and what we want to do is we want to
find
f of x equals to zero so it's root
finding this is in general a hard and
intractable problem sometimes it will
work sometimes it won't work okay if it
were really nasty function if it's
continuous great so why does this have
anything to do with what we care about
just as an aside remember
your your uh thinking here
if you want to minimize say l Theta and
it's convex or has a nice shape that's
the same as L Prime theta equals zero
sorry if that's too small right so if I
want to minimize something it's the same
as finding or finding the roots of its
derivative right
assuming it's convex double shaped
okay so they're related clearly all
right so what how does this thing
actually work so the idea here
is and probably you've seen this method
at some point maybe in a cowgirls class
or somewhere and it's it's a good method
but it's it has trouble with machine
learning and I want to talk about why
okay so here we have Theta zero we take
our guess F of theta zero and we compute
the gradient okay remember the
derivative in this case because it's one
dimensional is the directional of
maximal increase right that's the
function of the way the function is
increasing that's what the the
derivative is actually giving us
now what we're going to do is we're
going to follow the derivative
to where it crosses the axis okay so our
guess is going to be
Theta 1.
now you should kind of convince yourself
it's not true everywhere but almost
always if you think about picture of
function in your head that crosses zero
this is going to be a pretty interesting
way to find the zeros and to get closer
in fact this method is insanely fast for
a large class of functions it's called
what's called quadratically faster which
I'll emphasize again but it means you
get two you get twice the number of
digits of precision as you run it's
wildly fast okay when it runs in terms
of steps that it takes
okay so this distance we want to call
Delta so Theta 1 is going to be equal to
Theta 0 minus Delta
what is Delta how far do we step then we
have an algorithm here right and then
we'll repeat it right just to be clear
we go up here we would compute another
derivative
and so on and we would we would zoom in
on this this would be our Theta 1. or
Theta 2. okay so we have to solve this
key step so how big is this
well
if we look at it
F of theta 0
equals
F Prime of theta zero
times Delta okay it's just a triangle
rise over run that's all I'm doing
that's it okay that means Delta
equals F Prime of theta 0 which I'll
write in kind of an obfuscated way
times F Theta of zero
okay oops that is that looks terrible
let me erase that
there you go inverse okay so I have to
do an inversion okay
so this gives us the rule
Theta t plus 1 equals Theta t
minus
F of theta t
over F of theta T Prime okay this is our
roof finding algorithm and as I said
this thing converges crazy crazy fast
right so it like you know if you go to
0.1 then the next iteration will be 0.01
this is error going to be 0.0001 right
this is the error this is what quadratic
speed means that's insane you don't have
that many digits on your uh you know on
your device like it'll you know get to
machine Precision very very quickly now
this algorithm looks great like in one
Dimensions it's quite good but there's a
problem with it when we scale up to
higher dimensions and the problem we
scale up to higher Dimensions is right
here
the way that you write the higher
dimensional version of this rule is
Theta t plus 1 equals Theta t
minus and I'm going to write the the
typical way we do this H inverse
gradient and I'm going to put it in the
way that we would use it
okay so what have I done here let me let
me unpack this it's a little bit obtuse
okay so when we want to when we want to
generalize to vectors so we want to
generalize and use for minimization
we get here so Theta is remember our
front end Rd plus one
right L Theta becomes our our F Theta
right as we were using it above right
I've written it as a gradient with
respect to this
this thing here if you remember your
your Calculus
this is the Hessian
how big is that thing
well
it's in D plus 1 cross D Plus 1.
all right this thing is small this thing
oh it's not small this thing is small
it's in a this is an RD
now
one thing that is thing definitely by
the way if you don't remember what the
hestian is
H I J equals in this case uh I'll write
it as L Theta
is the Matrix of second partial
derivatives
all right
okay so it's all the mixed partial
derivatives
okay if you remember this from your
Calculus class if not don't worry I'm
sure a brief refresher will be fine a
couple things that are great about this
algorithm first is notice there's
nothing there there's no step size
there's no Alpha this thing just runs
okay this is a great algorithm in
machine learning Antiquity like 2003 and
4 2006 people use this algorithm because
it carried over from statisticians this
is how statisticians would solve
logistic regression so like if you go
into R I think up until very recently
maybe even still and you say like solve
logistic regression it will use this
algorithm under the covers and the
reason is it will get super super
accurate right it'll get all that fill
up all your digits and be very very
efficient in terms of how many steps it
takes but each one of those steps for a
machine learning problem could blow out
your memory
if you imagine you have a machine
learning model that has a billion
parameters a billion squared is a lot
right it's huge it will blow out your
system and so people have ways of
relaxing this uh over time that they try
to get more information in but it hasn't
historically been worth it okay
so does this algorithm make sense do you
recall this algorithm happy to answer
questions about it
all right so let's do a rough comparison
and if you want please ask questions
about I mean anything I guess but you
know relevant's fine oh I think I have a
chart for this okay
okay so let's look back at the methods
we've seen because I want to put them in
context
we saw this SGD algorithm pure SGD every
iteration took one data point
right we looked so I want to compare the
methods so we're clear on the method
name how much they cost per iteration
that is every time I take a step and
change the model that's what I mean by
pre iteration
how much compute do they do as a result
of that per iteration and how many steps
do they take to the error to the air
right this is kind of the conversion
straight off so SGD has a pretty bad
estimate of the underlying gradient but
you can go super fast relative to the
size of the model so you take many of
them and you kind of make up for it in
some situations
so let's see this so to compute here
this is proportional to D does not
depend on the size of your data set
there are situations where you can train
these models you don't even see all of
your data you only sample a small
actually there are models that people
pay money for that they have huge huge
collections of of data and they only ran
on the first like 30 percent of it and
they released the model there they're
like hey we sampled from it it was fine
right it was fast enough if you ran even
a single episode of batch gradient
descent
batch batch grading descent
you would have to look at all the data
points
which would potentially be much much
slower okay so it takes time at least
o-n-d put data's here although I don't
really mean them formally
okay
and then there's Newton's method
Newton's method also looks at all data
points
it's extremely expensive we won't talk
about how expensive you can get it
slightly down from this but and I've
written papers with other people and a
lot of people have tried to improve this
method but it literally like it's huge
it has this D Squared is going to kill
you okay you can try and get around it
because you have to compute the
interaction those those remember these
partial differentials here these are
like the interactions between every pair
of variables that you have that's a lot
of information quadratically more
okay so that's where their D Squared is
okay now these things are super fast I'm
gonna be a little bit glib here because
I'm not going to State the true precise
running time this thing is really fast
if you want to get to Epsilon error you
take log 1 over Epsilon steps right
potentially a little bit less than that
too but it's fine that's super fast okay
like you have an Epsilon of 10 to the
minus 16 log of 10 to the minus 16 is
like take a couple hundred steps and
you're done that's wild SGD a couple
hundred steps it's likely still spitting
out random values okay
in contrast
at The Other Extreme this is like
Epsilon to the minus two this is like
Epsilon to the minus one approximately
these are very vague Notions these are
this is only under some considerations I
just want to give you Engineers
intuition of how well these work okay
and the point is is that like there's a
clear trade-off here of how expensive
each one of these points are
versus how many steps you have to take
so if like you had a Computing device
that made it absolutely instantaneous to
look at all end data points
simultaneously then maybe batch gradient
descent makes sense because you would
just take steps really really fast if
you had an oracle that could compute
Hessians right which is what people
tried to do for a while and compute them
really really quickly then you would
prefer this algorithm right so it's a
trade-off between size and speed now we
tend to operate as machine Learners in
situations increasingly whether it's a
good idea or not I happen to like the
idea of huge huge models trillions of
parameters are the new like thing people
care about it's wild
Computing a trillion squared if you
thought a billion squared was bigger
trillion squared is bigger right but
about a factor of a million it's huge
so we can't run on those those kinds of
models and we tend to train on data sets
that are much much larger over time now
that how what much larger means changes
every generation of Hardware like every
two to four years what we mean by that
changes but like you know we train on
the web like all emissions or like all
of the we still can't train on all the
video right there's more video that's
put out there than we can possibly train
on we would like to be able to do that
eventually Hardware will catch up and
hopefully
the same dumb algorithms will work
that's our that's what we're praying
right now we have no we have no
justification for that statement
okay now the one thing that I
highlighted last time
is G the one thing I highlighted last
time was there's a little character that
squeezes in here called mini batch
right we talked about this very briefly
what minibatch does is instead of said
electing one points it randomly selects
B points
now its estimate is somehow better than
SGD
but not not kind of theoretically
doesn't change the curve the point is
for modern machine learning you can do a
sample of B things in parallel in the
same wall clock time that you can do one
and that's what's kind of distorted us
to use these batch methods really
candidly there's a little bit of error
reduction in the noise like you get a
better estimate of the gradient but
really it's because it's free for the
compute device the way a GPU works or
any of these kind of batch kind of
parallel systems you put in D points
they can do them all in parallel so
that's the thing that's lurking under
the covers because after the election
people ask me like well why would you
prefer that you're still taking the same
number of steps in batch gradient versus
SGD and it's because of this parallelism
that's underneath the covers we can
we've built Big parallel machines
Humanity right like your phone has an
ungodly number of teraflops in it like
super computer level teraflops some
number of years ago and we'll continue
on that thing so that you can get your
photos tagged I mean I don't know that's
how it works anyway so those are why we
do mini batch right okay
so far so good
all right any other questions
all right so the last thing I'll just
put on the on the thing here is in
classical stats these were all things
that people cared about
classical stats D was really small
and N was you know kind of moderate size
like if you look at where if you talk to
like your friends in the social
scientists who are like you know maybe
they're not doing the same thing now but
for a while ago when they would solve
these models when they would solve these
models D would be like a hundred right
and they really cared what their
responses were down to you know very
very fine levels
you have to run for a really long time
to get that level of accuracy for SGD
what machine learning is about in a
really fundamental way is like taking
these kind of bigger models and kind of
solving them approximately and weirdly
enough they end up pretty robust which
is something kind of horrifying we don't
understand it please
oh yeah so it means at least so I mean
like the Big O style notation it means
asymptotically it grows at least this
fast it's a little bit slower but I
don't want to kind of get into it
wonderful question yeah please
[Music]
awesome question so one one access that
you could also look on here is how how
well do they handle kind of noise in the
data and SGD turns out to be kind of
remarkably robust and you know there's
some versions where you can prove this
so when you're optimizing so
there's folklore around this we'll talk
a little bit about this but SGD because
it's noisy some there's some belief that
it doesn't get stuck in local Minima as
frequently as some of the other
algorithms do if you imagine this
picture
right right here imagine that it went
back up all right then somehow like
you're using all these second order
information to race you down to the
closest local Minima that's potentially
not what you wanted the entire time so
there's some folklore theory that says
SGD is a little bit better and I say
folklore because we can only nail that
down in some cases they're basically
theorems that say of the form like if
your data looks like this then this
happens or for certain things I'll show
you in a couple weeks this happens for
like solving certain Matrix equations
you can you can prove that it happens
there so that's another access the other
axis which you may think about if you're
an Optimizer is how numerically stable
is the underlying algorithm and here's
the thing that's pretty wild about
machine learning the trend has been not
to make more numerically stable things
so if you care about how a computer
works you have doubles inside double
precisions floating Point numbers now
you know if you saw nvidia's last
announcement they're going down to fp8
which means instead of 64 bits for a
number they're using only eight bits
there are people right now training with
integers
those methods we really only know how to
do over SGD because these methods you
you kind of Can't Get Enough meaningful
information in there so there's another
argument about how kind of statistically
robust they are
um and how numerically stable they are
they're not very numerically stable
there's a lot of tricks we're pretty
primitive there compared to like you
know the optimizers of the world but
yeah wonderful questions
awesome
fantastic
um any other questions
okay great so we're going to end a
little bit early today uh what we're
going to do uh on the and and know like
in general like you have to stay at l445
but today we got through it
um next time we're going to talk about
our exponential models these are going
to be models that have a more complex
link function and allow us to model more
of the world that's around us and kind
of interesting noise things
see you have fun I'll stick around for a
couple questions